Từ các vị, sang nay chứ tính nước lưng cường và phương nhân đã chùi gì lệ đón trọng thế,
tùng thống pháp Emmanuel Macron của với phương nhân đang thăm cấp nhận nước tư Việt Nam.
Pì là chuyên thóc hiện năm đầu tiên của một tổng thống pháp từ gần buổi nước qua,
và cũng là chá đời đoàn lệnh đạo cốc cao đồ tiên giữa hai nước.
Kể từ nâng cấp quan hệ lệ đội tá chính lợp tàn diện vào tháng buổi nước ngoái,
nhên truyết thông của tổ bị thư chú tính nước to lâm.
Chú tính nước lương cường cho mừng tổng thống Macaron,
vào đoàn đại biểu cấp cao pháp thăm tâm nhận nước tới Việt Nam.
Nynh mạnh mối quan hệ gần kết về lệ sự vành hoa sự hành nước.
Khẳng định chuyến thông là mình chính gió lệ cho cấp tâm đường quan hệ đội tá chính lợp tàn diện Việt Nam Pháp,
đi vào thú chất và hiệu quả.
Chú tính nước Nynh mạnh, pháp lương có vị trí quan trọng trong trí xác đối ngoại của Việt Nam
là cũng sẽ ủ tổ tiên Việt Nam có phán hệ đội tá chính lợp tàn diện, mất quan hệ thông đất.
Chú tính nước ngương cường khẳng định, Việt Nam lượng có trọng phát triển quan hệ đội tâm nhiều mặt với pháp.
Uống hộ pháp có phá trọng quan trọng trong các tổ chức quốc tế như liên hợp quốc,
tổ chức pham nữa và uống nè Scall.
Đi nghĩ hai nước tiếp tục phát viện những lợp thế tương đồng,
nhằm cựn nhau ứng phó với các thay thức quan cầu và sự lý hài hoa các vấn đề mỗi nổi của khu vực và thị giới.
Tổng thống Macaron về tỏng mừng lần đầu tiên đến thông Việt Nam,
nước có vài trọng quan trọng trong a xiang và trọng chính lợp ở tổ chức dân thái vị dân của pháp.
Tổng thống pháp về tỏng tượng chưa sự phát triển nghen trọng,
mạnh nẽ và những hình thịt phát triển kỷ tế sau hộ vực bật,
mà Việt Nam tắt được trong thời gian qua.
Chung mừng vì thế và vài trọng nghe càng cao của Việt Nam trong khu vực và triển trình tế.
Tổng thống phói.
Tổng thống khẳng định pháp mong muốn cùng Việt Nam tiếp tục tăng cơ hợp tắc trên các liệu vực trên thống.
Đặc biệt là í tế giám dụng, vẫn hoa,
năng lượng mới, giữ lịch sử, tương sứng với quan hệ lối tác chiến lược toàn diện hẹn này.
Hài nhà lễn đạo, đạo thung báo cho nhau về tình gình tế sau hội của mũn nước,
tình giá về các bước phát triển của quan hệ sông phương trong thời gian qua.
Tổng thầy chào đổi và thung nhất về các phương hưởng hợp tác lưỡn,
giữa hai nước trong thời gian tối, về chiến chiển hoại sau.
Hài bên nhất chỉ tiếp tục tăng cường cho đổi đoàn tiếp xuất các cấp,
đặc biệt là tốt cao trên tốt cả các cây.
Chị khách hiệu qua các cơ chế hợp tác hiệp có,
đồng thời gian kiểu thế lập các cơ chế hợp tác mới,
tiếp tục với hợp cho trẻ tại các diện nạn cúp đế và cú vực.
Chủ tình nước lương cường và tổng thủ phát,
cụn nhất chỉ hài nước cần tiếp tục trên khách các thỏng thuật đặt kiế,
trong các lĩnh người thật tác, trong lĩnh vực, cú phòng, anh em, trong đó,
gọi đấu tranh phòng trống tổ phạm, xin biệt dưới.
Nên sịm này, chủ tình nước lương cường đã mời lạnh nảo cốc cao phát,
tham dự lẽ ki cũng ước của liên được quốc,
trong tổ phạm mạng tại hà nội trong tháng 12.
Hài bên rất chỉ thuật đại thương mại đủ tư,
trên khai và hay thang hiệu qua hiệp định thương mại trử dụng phản nằm mèu.
Pháp sẽ thuật đại năm sớm hoàn tất phê trần hiệp định vào hộ độc tư A5 Việt Nam,
thuật đại vì bán châu Âu, sớm gỡ bỏ thay vàng i Wu,
đối với hàng thuì sản Việt Nam và tạo đủ kiet,
được Việt Nam tăng sức khẩu phía sản vào thị trường phát và A5.
Hài bên rất chỉ thu tại hợp tách trong lệp bỏ khoa công nghệ,
được mề sản thảo chỉ tệ nhân tạo, bán dẫn và chuẩn đủ số.
Đặc biệt là đạo tạo mình như lực trên lượng cao,
tông thêm mở sộ hợp tác nghiệp kíu khoa học,
thuật đại chuyển sạo và làm chủ công nghệ,
tổ tương phát triển hạ tổ số.
Hài nhẹ lệnh đạo thống nhất tất tổ tăng cường và thu tại hợp tách trong cây lịch được hợp tác chuyển thống,
dây sạo rụt, sạo tạo, y tế và tư pháp,
cũng như trong lệp bỏ khoa, đúng nghiệp và ứng khoa với bín đủ khi hầu.
Hình nằm tình như pháp, tế tổ khối trợ trong hợp tác phát triển thông qua tại trợ bốn Oda.
Wốn phải em đãi của chính phủ cho các dự án về tăng cường khả năng trống chữ với đủ khi hầu.
Nên cao chế lợp, bổ nế lực trong lệp bật năng lợp.
Pháp tế tổ khối trợ kệ tham, sìa thay các dự án cục thế,
trong khun cột quanh hiện lối tác chuyển lỗi năng lợp công bằng.
Nên dịp này, chú tính nếu lương cường cảm ơn và đề nghị chính phủ pháp,
tiếp tục quan tâm, tạo được kiện thuật lợp cho cột đồng người Việt Nam,
một địa của sống và hội nhập tốt để tiếp tục có đồng góc trước tựa cho phát triển kinh tế sảo hội của sơ tài.
Và tình hiếu nghĩ giữa hai nước, tình nghĩ pháp sống khẩn định việc tổ chức hội ý hợp tác hiện phương lần thứ mề ba.
Chào đổi về các bệnh đẹp của vật và có tế cùng của tâm,
chú tính nếu lương cơ khẩn định, Việt Nam kinh định chỉ xác có phòng của không.
Hãy bên khẳng định và cho tiếp yêu của chủ nghĩa đa phương trong đó đến hợp quốc dưới chỉ trong tâm.
Tổng thống mặt rông khẳng định, ông hộ lợp trường ASEAN về biển đông.
Hãy bên tái khẳng định cảm kết xuống trị hợp bình, ông định Anh Tuan và tự do hành hải,
hành không tại khu vật.
Giải quyết các trái chấp, ông định pháp hợp bình.
Chên cứu sở lợp pháp cuối tế và ông hộ mọi nỗ lợp.
Năm song đã được bộ quy tác ứng sự ở đeàn đồng gíu lợp thực chất phù hơn với lợp pháp cuối tế.
Chết thúc khội đầm sự tình nước mường bạm tổng phượng ASEAN bặt rông.
Tại吹 kiên các buộc ngành dân gi也 phải được cho đôngodle muy vốn tàn kện hưởng tác.
Bough cộng ý định thử giữa bốc có phòng và bộ cộn độc pháp về phần cửa khó sồng định được trang bị phòng.
Hãy đi hưởng về lĩnh luộc trữ Vế hoại hợp tác về cùng tác thư pháp vòng giữa về pháp tuần nông nghiệp và Muhs yồng.
Y định thư về thuốc tệ hợp tác ra thù bệnh tại, việc định hợp tác về khoa công nghệ và đủ mười sang tạo.
Y định thư về hợp tác trong sự đụng lắm đựa hạt nhân vì buick bếng hoa bình.
Y định về hợp tác giận trở lại công dân.
Thỏa thuật may cho dễ ổng hàng, sỏi lợp nhập lột thích ứng biến đổi khi hậu.
Bình bản thường lế hợp tác chung, chìm hai vệ tình quan sát sẽ đất.
Bình bản thỏa thuật hợp tác khai thác càng.
Hợp đồng tí dụng vài chợp dự án tăng cường lế định.
Hợp thuật đối tác về chuyển sạm công nghệ sản xuất phát xin tại Việt Nam
giữa xan Luv y paster và công ty của phần Vác xin Việt Nam VNC
và hợp đồng 1 ban 2 meto y thần dầu.
A bà bà bà mười chính tròm giữa biệt sát và em ước.
Nằm tăng thêm, chuyến cho các đường bay của bật châu Á thái bình dương.
Và ra mắt các đường bay dài đến châu Âu.
Hành lạnh đạo cũng gặp gỡ bao chiế, thông tin, cành những tế khoảng đối bật của hợp đồng.
Tôi và nài thần thống đó có cuộc hỏi đầm rất thành công.
Chúng tôi đã thống nhất các phương hướng và biển pháp để làm xấu xác hướng nước,
quan hề hợp tác nhiều mặt giữa hành nước.
Chúng tôi khẳng lấy lòng tin chi lược nè cảnh được cùng cố.
Trong với cảnh kinh tế vàng cầu, tăng có nhiều bến đọc phức tạm.
Hại bình rất trí rằng,
chủ có kinh tế thương mai và tắt phát triển tiếp tục là đồng lực quan trọng
cho quan hệ sòng phương.
Thái bình khẳng kết phố hợp chả chế, nhằm ruy trì và cùng cố.
Từ gió thương mai,
mà cơ hình nữa thì chương trời nhau và tiếp tục,
chẳng khai hợp qua hiếp đình thương mai,
từ gió phép Nam, Hè Hù.
Lực nhiệt Nam, mình trong những phía.
Hình Nam là chẳng lột tiến của tôi trong chuyến công su lần này.
Tôi có thể khẳng được pháp,
lánh giả rất cao một con hệ gắn gái dựa ai nước.
Mong muốn thái bình, cầm nhau dạc quyết,
nhưng thách thức và xây dụng từ lại thình vừa nghiệp lòng.
Về Nam đọng đọng vức và kính nguyên mới với một tiêu trở thành nước phát triển gặp giữa thế kỳ.
Truyền tôi mọi mỗi trở thành đối tác hàng đầu,
để hỗ trợ các bạn đạn nhử tương ai hợp.